I'm super excited to have a Robin Louis today that has joined us to talk about
her game changers book.
And,
uh,
both Google,
Google and Gigglers,
uh,
are happy to welcome you and I know she's going to give her life story.
So,
uh,
without further ado,
Robin,
thank you.
Just say,
Gosh,
what a pleasure.
What a pleasure to be here with you guys.
Um,
let's see.
I wanted to just start out with a quick introduction.
My name is Robyn Lawley.
Yeah,
she said,
and um,
I started this blog called a pocalypse smart lesbian commentary about eight
years ago.
Just inviting,
uh,
lesbians to like tell their stories and um,
I publish events and just interesting things,
authors,
things like that.
So it kind of led me to the book,
but before we get started,
I wanted to just ask your advice about,
um,
about my Halloween costume.
I had two choices.
One is the clowns and these are clown candidates.
It says,
you know,
vote flappy and crappy for Congress.
That was pretty funny.
So we tried that one on and we tried on the cat costume.
So which,
which do you think we should do?
Oh,
you like clowns.
That's so good.
So they scare people.
Anyway.
I like to be a little scarier than,
you know.
I don't know.
Anyway,
so I'm okay.
Yeah,
maybe we'll do that.
So this is the agenda today.
We're just going to talk a little bit about me and,
um,
a few other things.
You can take a look at that
and we have some good giveaways.
Okay.
So growing up I didn't have any role models really.
Um,
it was a pretty scary time in the sixties and seventies.
And when I first moved here to California from Chicago,
I was about seven and I rode my sting ray around it.
Look just like that actually.
And without a shirt on,
until that just wasn't okay anymore.
And what,
what we did was,
um,
what I did was like beat up boys after school.
Um,
we'd sneak out at night,
we were just trouble.
My friends and I,
and you know,
it became evident early on that,
um,
that I really liked girls and I was just,
I would,
I would stand in front of the mirror and like flex my muscles.
And,
um,
I had two ideas in my head that I was sure about,
one that I was never going to marry a man and to that I was never going to have
a baby.
So those things ended up,
one of them ended up changing,
but I was so,
I couldn't have been more sure of anything in my life.
Now I also was a big sand lot,
a softball player,
baseball player and I wanted to play little league so bad and I was really good.
And um,
at that time,
and this was pre title,
if you can imagine,
they didn't have to let girls play so I wasn't allowed to play.
Um,
so I joined Bobby sock softball team,
which was called the great American girls.
And we had a coach who was kind of a butchy mom type and we all had big brothers
and we,
we played so hard,
we were sliding into home.
And saying no batter and we handily won the championship.
And then at the end when they were passing out the trophies,
it ended up that they said,
I'm sorry,
but the Great America American girls are disqualified.
We're going to give the trophy to the buttercups,
uh,
because the,
the great American girls did not play in a lady like manner.
So if you can imagine a time when it was not okay to be competitive or a Tom
boy.
So that was the message I was getting pretty loud and clear.
Okay.
And so then when I became a teenager,
I applied to be a park ranger and I became the first park ranger.
This is a shot of me with a current park ranger that I ran into and I didn't
have to wear the man pants in the man boots at the time.
I could wear like cute tennis shoes and really tight pants,
like the kind that you lay down and zip up and a big old shirt with badges and a
big key ring.
And I just thought that I was so cool and I would stand around daydreaming about
the girl I was crushed out on.
Um,
then I got to high school and I really tried hard to be straight.
I,
you know,
I had a very feminine look and I just,
I got a lot of attention from men and so I just didn't know what to do.
So I tried really hard and it didn't work.
Um,
when I got to college,
I went to a summer in Europe where I met another woman who was also,
um,
had never been with a girl and we both were stumbling around.
It was a very awkward time,
but we got through it.
And then after that I finally moved to San Francisco where I finally found my
people and we lived on Castro street in 1982 I met this woman and we started a
family.
After about seven years,
um,
we each had a boy.
My brother was the donor for the older boy,
and then she couldn't get pregnant again the second time we wanted to.
And so I had to step up and it was terribly difficult as an athlete to be
pregnant.
And that picture on the bottom is my son and I,
we look exactly the same.
I got to say it's one of the most empowering things that I've ever been through.
Like an Amazon,
like to give birth.
Like here I was a little kid thinking I can never do this.
And um,
it ended up being really awesome except for ruining my body.
And
he cried for five years straight,
pretty much.
Um,
but when he got a little older and it was cool because I couldn't have really
had a baby with a man,
I wasn't really that great with infants.
And My,
my ex partner love to just stay home.
She,
I worked really hard.
I was so happy to go back to work and she took care of the infants and,
um,
so they're really good kids.
So then at this time we had to this,
okay.
We were the first wave of parents,
um,
other people that were having children that were older than us,
but there was no real group of parents.
So we were in San Francisco at this time when we had like a gay PTA and we had a
very inclusive campus.
Um,
and it was just,
it was nice,
you know,
but we still had to do this thing where we adopted each other's kids because we
couldn't be legally the parent of our own child or I couldn't be the legal
parent of the child she gave birth to and vice versa.
So we had to literally give up our children to each other and the judge would
just,
I remember we had to go to court twice and he would just like point at us and
say,
are you sure you want to give up your child?
And I'm like,
oh my God.
It was really intense.
Um,
and then we got married,
we,
uh,
went down to city hall.
Gavin Newsome made it okay to go down and we ran down there and um,
it was exciting.
And My,
my youngest was eight and he was like,
oh,
Yay.
This means you'll be married forever.
You'll always be together.
And unfortunately that wasn't the case.
But what happened that was cool about that was that he,
you know,
he just felt so validated by us being able to be married.
So I feel like that's such an important,
um,
it's just an important thing when you think about,
the whole right for same sex marriage,
that the kids are the ones that are being hurt by it so much.
And
so we,
um,
got,
are a marriage certificate mailed back to us after about,
I think it was less than a month later,
it arrived in the mail as a node because the law didn't stick.
So then at that point we moved to Marin county.
That's where I grew up,
as you saw.
And I wanted my kids to have a more rural existence.
So I brought them to Marin and my oldest came home saying,
uh,
God,
Mommy,
why is everybody saying you're so gay,
you fag?
And he just didn't understand.
It was shocking for him.
And I was like,
well,
we're not living in San Francisco.
It's not a bubble anymore.
So he became a,
the kind of kid who told his friends,
look,
I'm not going to be your friend if you say stuff like that.
And you know,
I don't know.
I got,
I got motivated to go into the schools and become a speaker for the LGBT
speakers' bureau to be a coach for the little league team,
the coach for soccer,
and just be visible and like help them.
I mean,
like things would happen.
Like I'd have kids over for the soccer party and I'd say,
Timmy,
what are you doing out there?
And he'd say,
Oh,
we're playing smear the queer and,
you know,
in the backyard.
I'm like,
what?
And you know,
so,
and it just went on and on.
Some of the dads would say,
wow,
you really remind me of Ellen.
And I'm like,
why?
I don't look like her.
And we just had,
um,
there was a lot of homophobia in Marin.
And,
and,
and I think about all the people in the outlying areas right now.
I mean,
we live in such a bubble.
Um,
so I got the idea to write this book,
which is about lesbian heroes of my generation.
And,
and the women that they looked up to weren't,
it wasn't like they were bad,
it was just that the role models weren't very positive.
So they passed a law called the fair education act kind of recently.
And it really got me excited.
Like this was something that I could contribute to.
I could,
I'm a graphic designer and an editor and a curator and I,
I have a huge circle of people that I know and I,
I just thought I could make a really fun book that teenagers are gonna love.
And so,
um,
what this law does is it requires a LGBT education,
uh,
as far as history and social studies in the public school curriculum in
California.
And there's right now there,
it's not really like the curriculum exists.
It's not like really there's resources for them.
Um,
I attended a symposium last week where,
or two weeks ago where we,
we,
um,
got in a room and did a whole big think tank about how we're going to get this
to happen.
And it's clearly a couple of years out before they'll really be a lot of things
available to students.
And especially public schools don't have a lot of,
uh,
resources to spend on stuff like this.
So I got it in my head that I wanted to make this book and donate it to the
public high schools in Marin,
San Francisco,
Oakland,
and Berkeley.
So what I did was I decided to go crowdfunding and I got to say,
if you're a little insecure and you have a full time job,
this is a brutal way to go.
Um,
I was,
it was so excruciating.
I went at it to two different runs at it each for about 10,000,
and I'm,
no,
the money's not all from my family.
It really did get spread out amongst about 200 people.
I had an average of about a hundred each.
Um,
it required,
you know,
live Facebook videos,
Yay.
You know,
it's so scary.
Um,
anyway,
so I got all that money and then I was able to print the books and I was able to
deliver them to the 48 public high schools.
And it serves about 49,000 students now.
And these schools have invited me in to talk in their classroom.
I've been able to,
um,
just share with these kids and hear their stories.
And I had one girl come up to me just in tears saying,
oh my God,
I can't believe you're really here.
And she had,
um,
I had these books kind of sprinkled around some bookstores too,
like in the Castro and she said,
I got your book in the Castro and I'm,
I'm just,
I can't believe it,
you know,
and she was hugging me and crying.
It was like so gratifying.
Um,
so I wanted to show you my crowdfunding video,
see if I can get this to play.
My name is Robin Liliana.
I've been curator and editor of apocalypse smart lesbian commentary in the past
six years,
pioneering lesbian
mom of two grown sons.
I turned to my youngest Sam Age 20 to talk about what this book means to him
personally.
I was raised in Marin county by two lesbian moms.
As I grew up and went to elementary and middle school,
I noticed that we were never taught about gay people or their history.
So because of that lack of education,
gay slurs were rampant around campus and it was always kind of a struggle for
me.
I think you can help not only heterosexual students that are unclear about what
being gay really means as well as kids that might be coming out of the closet
and just want to find their own place in the world and be accepted.
And if you could spread the word to your network,
it would be a great help.
So thank you so much for your time.
Anyway.
Um,
I asked him to say that in his own words and he kind of gave me a hard time.
He's like,
I'm not going to,
I don't mommy,
I don't know what you know.
And,
and I was like,
oh no.
And then I just,
it and then one day he goes,
okay,
I'm ready.
And I just went outside and filmed him with my iPhone.
I got pretty lucky there.
That's a good boy.
And he's just not,
he's,
yeah.
Anyway,
so then I also got books ordered from schools in libraries all over the United
States.
People were hitting me up in like North Carolina and Texas and um,
it was just,
it's been super exciting.
I'm down to my last few books,
which I brought for you guys to raffle off,
so you're pretty lucky.
Then I won a,
an award for the best Lgbtq book by this,
um,
next generation indie book awards,
which was quite a,
it's quite an honor and I really didn't understand that.
It was such an honor.
I was kind of like,
Oh,
I got this award.
And then someone told me I've been trying to win that for years.
I can't believe you.
Anyway,
so here's a brief history of queer culture.
I just want to back up a little bit and talk about that.
The women in the book,
these are,
this is the kind of world that,
that I was a little girl and they were little girls in.
This is what we had.
Okay.
So there's Sappho who obviously was the first,
uh,
written word of a sonic to another woman that is arguably like the beginning of
Lesbian Ism.
And then Radclyffe hall came along in like 1929 and she,
um,
wrote a book called the well of loneliness.
It was,
um,
it was in the court system in the UK for a long time for obscenity,
and it finally made it to the u s um,
there was no explicit sexual content in this book whatsoever.
It was just that there was a mannish heroine who was,
I guess she liked the girls.
And then Gertrude Stein was in the 1930.
She was the first visible lesbian here in,
in America.
Um,
she was from Oakland and she wrote those famous quotes.
A rose is a rose is a rose and there is no there,
there in regards to Oakland.
And,
um,
she ran a salon like in Paris with people like f Scott Fitzgerald and Ernest
Hemingway and Matisse,
Picasso.
All these big speakers at the time would sit around.
And,
and then she got famous for writing the book about her partner,
Alice B Toklas,
uh,
called the autobiography of Alice B Toklas,
which is kind of random.
She,
she did it in the voice of her partner.
Um,
and just as an added fun fact,
my parents named our cat Alice.
And then later it came to light that his name was,
her name was Alice B Toklas.
This is when I was a little girl.
So that happened.
Okay.
So then this John recalled pulp fiction emerged and it had to do with just cheap
paper.
That's where they called the pope fiction.
And it was the first time that America could by just,
uh,
paperbacks cheaply at a news stand.
And,
you know,
you might finish reading it and leave it on your,
on your seat on the bus and someone else would pick it up.
And so it was,
it was just a way to get masses to be reading literature and,
and then within that genre became lesbian pulp fiction and,
oh,
my notes,
could you grab those from you Jane?
Anyway,
so,
um,
if you wrote this book,
a lot of times the women had pseudonyms that were men's names and you,
the publishers were required that you,
um,
had to say you literally had to have the heroin either die.
These are not with them.
It's in my bag anyway,
back to back to the lesbian publication.
So,
um,
you had to have the heroin either die,
go back to men or go crazy just like the films at the time.
It was,
it was,
this is what we had to look up,
dude.
This is what we saw.
Yay.
Thank you,
Jane.
Okay,
so,
um,
I want to just read you a quote of a woman who was a kind of an interesting
writer.
She's probably 80 now,
so she said a lesbian pulp fiction paperback first appeared before my
disbelieving eyes in Detroit,
Michigan in 1957.
I didn't need to look at the title for clues.
The covered leapt out at me from the drug store rack.
A young woman with sensuous,
sensuous intent on her face,
seated on a bed,
leaning over a prone woman,
her hands on the other woman's shoulders.
Overwhelming need led me to walk a gauntlet or fear up to the cash register,
fear so intense that I remember nothing more.
Only that I stumbled out of the store in possession of what I knew.
I must have a book as necessary to me is air.
The book was odd girl out by an Bannon.
I found it when I was 18 years old.
It opened the door to my soul and told me who I was.
And it led me to other books that told some of us who we were and how some of us
live.
So it just to imagine a time where it this something like this would be so
forbidden and so awesome to like not have any vision of yourself out in the
world.
And then,
then you got this kind of one that wasn't so great because you didn't have to
die or go crazy.
So in this one,
things started to change a little in the 50s.
Women's barracks actually was about,
um,
a real couple with a real relationship a little bit.
And so if it came under the scrutiny of the,
uh,
house UNAMERICAN activities committee where they,
um,
they had it up for it obscenity and they,
they said Lesbian Ism was a social logical disease in a cause for grave national
concern.
It could not be cured,
but it must be understood as a tragedy.
So it was accused of promoting more moral degeneracy.
This is because they crossed that line where they weren't having an unhappy
ending.
And I'm,
I mean,
I'm actually not sure about the ending,
but the fact that there was a real relationship was just too much.
Um,
this is kind of the McCarthy era too.
We're a little later,
but anyway,
but it helped really increase the sales and they sold like 4 million copies of
that.
Uh,
so this other book,
the price of salt,
this was,
did you see the movie Carol that came out a couple of years ago?
This was the movie,
um,
with Cate Blanchett,
I guess.
And this was the movie that they wrote it about.
And that one has sort of had a happy ending where the women got to stay
together.
She lost her child,
but
it wasn't all rosy.
Anyway.
So during that same time was an underground gay bar culture.
And um,
I guess it's saying that gay men and lesbians were now seen as a group to cure,
convert and suppress.
So the American public started to get wind of this thing and they got,
they were getting really mad.
You can't be out in public.
And so they were rounding up people.
This is around the time of stonewall.
Um,
so these women here,
you know,
there was a very butch and femme culture and like you,
if,
if you,
you could get caught for not wearing three,
um,
things have the same three articles of clothing,
of the assigned gender that you are,
you could be thrown in jail.
So I'm not sure if I would be thrown in jail.
Hopefully not.
Um,
but they had a little signals,
like they'd flashed the lights and everyone would switch to the opposite sex
partners so that they wouldn't be like thrown in the patty wagon.
But they were risking everything,
their jobs,
their lives,
their families,
just to be able to congregate.
Now at that same time was this thing called a couple of different secret
societies,
daughters of Bilitis.
This is Phyllis line and del Martin.
And their thing was that they were kind of the intellectual set and they didn't
really want to be associated with like the working class voters FREMM scene.
They wanted to be able to have a literary magazine they could send around.
And so they send it in like a brown paper bag.
And,
um,
so people all over the country,
we're getting some culture now finally.
So now I'm gonna talk a little bit about my game changers in the book.
So the way I set this up was I chose women who,
uh,
are not famous in the world at large.
They're famous amongst the gay and lesbian community.
So we have authors,
business women,
promoters,
actors,
publishers,
entertainers,
lawyers,
everybody that I could gather together that was connected to me on some first or
second degree,
um,
that was willing to give me all these pieces I needed to pull this book
together.
So you don't see people like Ellen and Rosie O'donnell and stuff in here because
they're already famous.
But it's,
it's more like our heroes that actually created real changes to the culture for
the young people today to know about.
Um,
so this woman,
uh,
Monica Palacios,
she was named,
um,
they had Monaco Palacios stay for her 30 year career as that you kind of lesbian
a performer and writer.
This is Judy delegates.
Um,
the,
she,
um,
is the Olivia person,
so they started Olivia and 73 as a music company and then now it's like a
multimillion dollar corporation.
And,
um,
she's doing really well.
And,
and you know,
I've been on a lot of these trips and I always find it fascinating,
women from across the country that don't live in our bubble save up all year
long to be able to afford this one week to be able to hold their partner's hand
and be out for a week.
It's,
it's incredible.
I,
it's,
I always forget just how lucky we are here.
Um,
and this woman crystal Jang is really interesting.
Each person had a page also that had like a pullout card,
which I'll show you,
but crystal,
um,
she was born and raised in China town and as a young woman,
in the 70s,
during that time the health department was sending people out to different
communities to talk about,
wow,
there's gay and lesbian people in the community and you need to address this.
And so when they got the Chinatown,
I guess the mayor of Chinatown Guy says,
look,
we don't have any gay people in Chinatown.
And so crystal,
um,
was just a young,
I think she was an educator.
She could lose her job.
She stood up and she said,
my name is Crystal Jang.
My parents are Esther and homer Jang and I'm a lesbian.
And it just like brought the house down and people were crying and coming up to
her.
And so she was the first one to like stand,
take a stand in the Chinese community and it's just so important.
She brought together the whole Asian community in one,
you know,
as a,
as a force in the gay and lesbian community within that.
And jewelle Gomez,
this is the fun fact cards that are in the book.
They're like little baseball cards.
She's a playwright of uh,
she does lesbian vampire novels and,
um,
she does,
you know,
uh,
James Baldwin inspired plays.
She's fantastic.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
the Dyna.
Um,
this is Mariah Hansen and what people don't know so much about her.
I don't know if you know about the Dinah,
it's the largest lesbian event in the,
in the world,
I guess.
And um,
zillions of lesbians descend on Las Vegas.
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
palm springs once a year and she has discovered acts like Lady Gaga,
Katy Perry.
She's the first one to have them out.
And so that is really a big hotspot for culture.
Um,
Kate Kendall who win as the leader of Nclr,
she,
um,
they are the ones that that brought,
gay marriage to be legal.
They're the ones that fought the fight.
Uh,
this is an interesting one.
This Diane Anderson.
Mitchell.
She's a woman I worked with years ago.
Um,
and she had a partner that Susie just kind of a average kind of quiet gow.
And then,
um,
over the years Susie transitioned to Jake and Jake is this swaggering handsome
dude now and they are still married all this time.
And then,
you know,
this interests me because it begs the question and she still lesbian.
Well she thinks she is.
I think she is.
So she belongs in there.
And this is Margaret Gomez who I got up,
I heard that this spit take thing became like the most famous meme on the
Internet and my son and one of the video called me up.
Mommy,
I keep seeing Marga on,
on video,
I mean on as a meme on online.
So she's managing to stay relevant.
She also has a show right now in Berkeley called,
um,
I forget the name but it's um,
it's really Latin standards.
Yeah,
you should definitely go see that.
If you get a chance is playing there right now at the marsh.
It's fantastic.
She plays her dad and her mom.
And,
and this is Jenny Olson,
who is the person who started planet out,
I dunno if you know about that.
That was one of the very first websites that meant so much to all of us that are
a little older.
Um,
it was the first place where you could have a hub of all things gay.
And,
uh,
my mom takes a look at this and says,
is that a man?
Then I say,
no,
that's Jenny.
And she's cute.
Okay.
So what's next for game changers?
Um,
well,
I'm hoping to get it in to 267 more schools,
which would serve an additional 22 over 200,000 students.
And that,
that means every county in the barrier,
every public high school would get a book and we put it,
I,
you know,
I put it in the wellness centers and the libraries I've heard from the wellness
center people in,
in my hometown,
how much it means to those kids to just walk in and like see that on the table.
Because that's who's typically going into the wellness center.
Someone who's being bullied or feeling a little awkward,
and if they can just pick this up and have it not be a big deal,
it's huge.
Um,
and this is why it's so important because it's not just the gay kids that are
going to benefit.
It's the straight kids.
It's like,
Gosh,
I don't know.
When I was little,
we didn't have like a poster of,
um,
we didn't have black history month.
We didn't have Martin Luther King and every classroom,
but now they have that.
So like I was picturing soon in a few years,
they'll probably have a picture of Harvey milk and every classroom a poster and
that's all great.
But like,
I want to make sure the lesbians are included.
That did great things because women are always left out of stuff.
And like the history history is always about the context with which you tell it.
So now,
oh,
we lost it,
ted.
Uh,
so the reasons that it's so great obviously is reduces bullying,
increases visibility and fosters pride and dignity.
Like that girl who just was so touched that I brought it in.
It just,
it's so important for people to see themselves.
Otherwise you just feel invisible.
So I'm just asking you guys to help spread the word today and I have a signup
sheet over there if you want to keep in touch.
No.
Hello.
Did you see any challenges?
Describe the books.
She asked if,
if we,
okay.
She asked if we,
if I face any challenges when trying to distribute the books and yes.
Um,
I got a couple of books mailed back and then,
but mostly no,
everyone was thrilled to get it and I,
I either mailed it or personally sent,
uh,
walked into these schools and gave it to him and I got all the right names from
some educator friends.
So it was going to the right people.
Hi,
this isn't about your book,
but your experience of the challenge of parenting in those situations.
And do you have any advice on handling those situations where you have other
parents that are not as open minded and well that's a really good question.
And how you've navigated that overtime at,
well,
I can only think of an anecdote that's pretty funny.
When my partner and I first moved to Marin,
some parents said to me,
Oh,
we always wanted a lesbian couple in our circle of friends.
We were like,
wow,
that's,
that's exciting.
Oh
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean I guess I just,
um,
you know,
my son is actually,
my older son is a real big advocate for that hip.
He'll say,
he'll just say,
oh,
so you're against it.
I mean like you think if I got hurt,
my mom shouldn't be able to pick me up from the hospital.
Like,
like just point out real facts about the discrimination and
I don't know,
it's a hard one.
It's very personal.
I guess.
I tried to steer clear of it as much as I could and give my kid the tools to
just be proud of himself by surrounding him by a positive environment and being
proud.
Like I,
I'm really proud that both my kids are feminists.
Like they just really get it about the discrimination and they see,
they consider themselves queer.
They're both straight,
but they,
um,
they know they were raised by two women and that has changed and that has made
them better.
Men,
I was thinking,
Oh God,
you're bringing two little white boys into the world and you know,
at least they've got this thing that makes them understand that,
you know,
it's not the same level playing field for all of us.
It's really important to know that.
Anything else?
Oh sorry
you had another question.
I did
keep it going.
I'm dominating this.
Okay.
It's okay.
Um,
do you uh,
do you have any recommendations for us if we want to approach schools as well to
help distribute your book?
Well,
you could contact me afterwards.
I would love,
I would love some help with that.
Especially when it comes to delivering it down here.
I've for a couple of grants and I'm also looking for people to step up and help.
So anyway,
you can help if it could be distributing and something like that would be
fantastic.
Or giving me the right people and yeah.
So you could sign up over here and I'll be sure to be in touch.
I did have somebody pinged me with a question,
which is,
first of all,
thank you for being here.
It's such an important publication and for documenting our history.
What are your thoughts on how millennials tend to identify more as queer that
the word lesbian could be fading from our lexicon?
Oh,
that's a great question.
Um,
I will say that when I came out and the women around my age,
we didn't have a choice.
It wasn't a choice of some version of queer.
It was,
it was you're a lesbian or you're not,
you like women or not.
And if we were going to choose that the harder way,
you know,
then we were going to claim it.
And so now that it's become kind of an on PC word to use in general for the
youth,
um,
I just have to question it.
I got a lot of 'em actually flack.
I got people emailing me saying,
do you have to use that ugly word?
Can't you just say queer?
Uh,
and I was like,
no,
cause it's about the lesbians.
I mean that's the whole point.
But um,
it's an interesting part of history.
And it will fade and it is fading and,
and that's okay.
It's just,
um,
it's important to at least understand why it was there,
what happened and why we have the freedoms that we have today to choose some
version of,
of gay,
queer,
whatever fluid.
Yes.
My experience growing up in Toronto,
when I started to try and tell people,
I found it hard to sell as a lesbian.
And I would say,
you know,
um,
so I would say I'm gay.
Like there's something about the stigma of,
of saying you're a lesbian and it started from the beginning.
Good point.
So almost in a way,
we're still not comfortable saying we're lesbians,
right?
It's a,
it's a misogynistic thought.
If you really think through,
why is it so uncomfortable to talk about the woman part of the gay thing and
identify as strictly as that and,
and when,
when the word gay is such a happy word,
and lesbians like,
Oh yeah,
thank you so much.
I really resonate with that.
And yeah,
it's,
it's so interesting how there's a,
there's that little hurdle about lesbian.
So I you started asking what we were going to come to Halloween as and I figured
it out.
I'm going to come as,
as a lesbian.
You should know.
And I wondered if you had any thoughts about what my costume should look like.
I dressed as a lesbian once for Halloween.
I wore a very misshapen pillow here and then a big old fanny pack and a mullet.
This was years ago.
I can't believe I did that.
But that's different than lesbian,
you should know,
right?
Of course.
Um hmm.
Maybe Bertrand style where you could hit your chain was in a friend way where
she played,
she,
there was a play called all these different Gertrude's and chain.
Literally cut her hair for the part that night.
I gave him a deal.
Worst haircut I've ever seen.
Fringe.
Okay.
That's a deal breaker.
I'm going as Amelia Earhart.
Oh,
nice.
Well,
we don't know about her.
No,
we'd have to wonder.
There's some letters.
Is there.
Oh,
nice.
There was a man that was an African American for a really long time.
And she finally,
she kept saying,
no,
no.
And then,
and there's all these letters back and forth about it,
and she finally said,
at some point,
she's like,
listen,
we all know that I'm not interested in this,
but I can't take the pressure of expectation anymore.
So if we're going to do this,
you have to understand that I'm going to go do my own separate thing.
And then she was in a horrible,
plaintiff didn't have to ever marry anybody.
Wow.
I wonder if that was rigged.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Any other question?
Questions?
All right.
Or thoughts?
Let's thank Robin for coming today.
Thanks.